yeah we don't have that that's become
local am radio ads pretty much
or 1 800 cars for kids which runs
which i shouldn't have said because
people yell at you when you just mention
it
why because they're so sick of hearing
that song and it's upsetting to see
those kids all dressed up and everything
i think they're the problem
wait cars for kids i never even thought
about it it was just such a catchy
jingle 1 800 don't do it i'm telling you
people are going to be writing all over
comments they hate why can't these kid
why can't these kids have cars
that's the better song that's better
wait what what do they do with those
cars
are they toy cars
you know i don't even know what it is i
think it's something that helps kids i'm
not sure and i'm not looking it up
but i i don't think we want to know
about it because the song is horrific to
me it's like a chucky movie when i hear
that song
i like that song and it reminds me of
some of your original music